this program is brought to you by Emory
University
we were interested in looking at how
much added sugars were being consumed in
the United States because we had
recently done a couple studies where we
looked at the association's of added
sugars with markers of cardiovascular
disease risk and in those days we had
found that the more added sugars people
consume the worse their cardiovascular
disease risk and that was true in adults
and in children but over the last decade
especially there's been a lot of public
health awareness and I think people are
starting to get the message about sugars
so we were interested to look and see if
we could understand where the sugars
were coming from and whether these
sources were getting better or whether
we were consuming more over time as a
society we actually found some what I
think is good news so added sugars as a
whole consumed by people in the united
states are going down so we're consuming
less now than we did 10 years ago there
and that was actually true in every age
group which I thought was pretty
exciting the biggest source for added
sugars in our culture it was sodas and
that sort that's actually where the main
change was and unfortunately I don't
think it's enough yet we were definitely
going the right direction the American
Heart Association recommended that we
get about five percent of our calories
from added sugars and in our study we
found that people had the original in
the 1999-2000 dataset people were
consuming about eighteen percent of
their calories rented sugar and over the
ten years it decreased to 14 and a half
which is much better but clearly 14 and
a half is still about three times more
than what would be a healthy amount
you
the preceding program is
Murray university